for the first nine months of this year
sales of say out cars were still healthy
during a visit of the Spanish Prime
Minister at the beginning of sep tember
the car maker announced it was going to
spend 3.3 billion euros on equipment
facilities and research and development
but since the diesel gate scandal broke
say it hasn't been allowing journalist
inside their works this is filed footage
sale is also not prepared to talk to us
others however have expressed their
concern the head of the factories works
council matthias canerro is still
waiting for confirmation that the
investment program will actually go
ahead and he's worried about the impact
of the Volkswagen emissions fixing
scandal on upcoming sales in October say
at sales and Spain dipped chica que
tener mucho Guido and low meetings could
be tricky in November and December
that's when the results of the scandal
will become visible know who knows how
this crisis will affect us because no
one knows how car buyers will react
whether people will go into the car
sales office or not this is an identity
crisis our image is at stake gotcha
porque tu suna chrissy de venta das una
at reseda imagine say at dealers have
been instructed not to speak to the
press but we can also gauge the mood of
customers by speaking to an independent
dealer joaquin cadena sells used cars in
the coastal town of mataró Volkswagens
Audi's and say arts in particular now
but I'll motel have been got a little
book of my sales of cars from the VW
group of almost ground to a standstill I
mean that worries me because they're the
ones i sell that's how I make my living
oh I've hardly soul any cars for about a
month now hey don't not home anymore
right many people are hoping that the
scandal will blow over soon but VW and
say at stony silence isn't exactly
reassuring Cardenas is also unhappy
about the situation you know but I'm
constantly getting calls from customers
who bought a VW from me but I don't have
any information VW Spain hasn't been
much help thought I'd Tomas say it's new
boards chairman had the chance of making
a public statement
automotive industry meeting in Barcelona
a few days ago but Luca de mayo
cancelled his appearance at short notice
experts believe say ads fate lies in the
hands of vw's top management I think the
real issue for C at is what role it's
going to play in the group and what will
be the group strategy as a result of the
crisis if folks wagon for example
chooses to push harder on electric
vehicles push harder on smaller vehicles
and if it's decided to give see at a
role to play in that strategy then this
could be a long run very good for sale
what at the moment this is pure
speculation say out on its expansive
strategy has got the full backing of the
Catalonian government it has just opened
a new 20 million euro training center in
the region to serve the auto industry
menu but trainees here are worried about
their future of course I'm worried we're
doing further qualifications so that we
can work in a sector what a production
is slashed they're going to need pure
designers and of course that will affect
us directly eNOS effect le dip them in
that little the only person whom we
spoke to with the positive take on the
situation is the mayor of mutter a savvy
air fauna Yosa most of the town's 28
thousand inhabitants work for say at or
for say at suppliers
isn't a matter gotten people there is a
brand with a very popular youthful image
the majority of the vehicles are
exported that's why I can't really
imagine my CR would be a source of
economic trouble for the VW Group Kanye
problemas economy goes al grupo but
Volkswagen my create problems for say at
after all valves Berg might decide to
slash the promised investment program to
help cover the cost of the emissions
scandal